(upbeat music)
- That's why Plato
was a huge jagoff.
(bell ringing)
Class dismissed.
- Wait but you didn't
give us any homework.
- Dave can I talk to you
for a second in private.
- Look if this is
about the dick pics,
I mean you can't just
say hey that's your dick.
- No, that' not, that's not it.
What do you mean by dick pics?
- My friend his name's
Dick and he's short.
- Okay.
Well listen Dave,
I understand that
you're quite a
competitor with women.
- You mean a player?
- Yes a player.
Now I'm getting into the
game and I needed some advice
'cause I'm going out with a very
high temperatured woman tonight.
- You mean hot woman?
- Yes hot Woman
Studies professor, yes.
- I don't think I can help you.
- Well then maybe I'll
do a little investigation
into those ding
dong photographs.
- I'll help.
- Good, thank you.
Okay, now what happens when a
woman and a guy, they go out.
(tinkling music)
I'm professor Rich,
expert in science.
These are my devoted students.
Together with the aid
of harmless drugs,
we explore sciences greatest
hypothetical questions.
(upbeat music)
E equals MC squared,
discovered by Albert Einstein.
What does it mean to us?
- Well it's perhaps the most
famous scientific equation
in all of history.
- Boom.
- Hmm if it's so famous then
why have I never heard of it?
- The beauty of this
equation is it's simplicity.
E which stands for
energy, equal mass times
the speed of light squared.
- So what you're saying
is E equals MC squared.
- Yeah, exactly.
But what if we were wrong?
What if E did not
equal MC squared?
- Well I guess
that would make it
two times that I
don't give shit.
- I don't know professor,
I mean it's a pretty
iron clad theory.
Countless scientists.
- Come on people
open up your minds.
(grunting)
Not that way Pat.
I needed to speak to
someone well versed
in Einstein's
field of expertise.
So I tracked down a
professor on the internet.
So if you could explain
in the simplest terms
Einsteins' equation
E equals MC squared.
- Oh of course.
- I mean I know it, but.
- When Einstein came up
with that equation the basic
statement he was making
was that you can get energy
from mass and from mass
you can get energy.
And what made those equal was
C the speed of light squared.
So E is equal to MC squared.
- What if we turn this
on it's head and said,
what if E did not
equal MC squared?
- Right.
- I know I have trouble
carrying the one,
what if Einstein
forgot to do that.
- The main question we have
is how does general relativity
tie into quantum mechanics
which is the small scale.
Once we are able to do
that we're gonna be able
to tie the big structure of
the universe to the tiny atom.
- I have a question.
- Sure, go ahead.
- I'm having a date
tonight and I was wondering
if I should wear a bolo tie?
- Well do you have a really
good cowboy hat to go with it?
- I have no hats.
- Then you shouldn't
wear a bolo tie.
- Thank you very much.
(upbeat rock music)
- Wow.
Nice outfit, midlife crisis.
- Thanks.
- Here's the thing you just
don't wanna do anything weird.
Laters.
- Wait, where are you going?
I need you to be my wing man.
(laughing)
- On a date?
No that is a bad idea.
- I need you to give me
some advice like close by
like those ear piece shows.
I don't wanna end up with soup
all over me or something, no.
- There she is.
Okay just go.
Yeah go.
- Hello, I'm Professor
Susan Camberwell.
You must be Professor Rich.
- Enchante.
Um who gives a shit right?
- Right, well um, shall
we get something to eat
or is that too
compassionate for you?
(laughing)
- Oh!
- Made you flinch.
- Why?
- I dunno, it's fun.
Food here is very
underrated don't you think?
- I usually don't come here.
I'm a strict vegan
so I go off campus.
Have you ever been to
Papadums Don't Preach?
- Yes, I mean no,
but I mean I think
off campus is very underrated.
- Where do you go, like what?
- Local Art.
- Oh, have you been to
Schwartz's Gallery they feature
these art paintings
directly from vaginas.
- Ow!
- It's a ghost.
Ah I gotta go, great date.
(shrieking)
- God, I knew this
plan wouldn't work.
I tried to tell him.
I'm sorry.
I'm David.
- Hi.
- Fucking soup.
I was confused.
I needed to speak
to the man himself.
Surprisingly I found
him on the internet.
In 5,000 words or less
how would you describe
your special Theory
of Relativity?
- E equal MC squared where E
equals energy, M equals mass,
C equals the speed of light.
The speed of light is
186,000 miles per second.
- Okay Einstein.
- Yeah.
- No really.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh keep going.
- So it was that equation that
gave birth to the atomic bomb.
- Have you ever been
wrong about anything?
- Well I have to think
real hard about that one,
but I denied quantum mechanics,
and I was wrong about that one.
- Is it possible that E
doesn't equal MC squared?
I rest my case.
- No it's not, it's impossible.
When the light went near
the Sun, then it bent.
- Right.
- That took care of that.
- Explain please.
- It's in the math.
- So wait, wait, wait, wait.
You expect us to believe that
you met with Albert Einstein?
- Did he say that his
theory could be wrong?
- Well you know, humans
are wrong, he said,
so his theories could be wrong.
He loves Warcraft by the way.
- [Girl Student] Oh.
- Really?
- [Rich] Yeah.
- Maybe I should
look into this guy.
- Oh hi Susan, what
brings you here?
- I just came to apologize.
- Oh don't worry I mean I think
we got of on the wrong foot.
- Uh I'm sorry I had to
leave your dorm so fast,
I had an early class.
- Oh don't worry about it baby.
You forgot your toothbrush.
- Thank you.
And thanks for that dick pic.
- Ah if it's long,
send it along.
(laughing)
- Come here.
- You want a kiss or something?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
(bright music)
- I'll see you later.
- Wait.
- Okay.
- That's how you do it.
(upbeat music)
- My first marriage
I had two children.
- Uh huh.
- And then like I said she
wasn't taking care of me.
- Exactly.
- So I finally, my cousin.
- If you're cousin's
around why not?
- And so we got married.
- Right.
- Actually I wanted to
marry my cousin's daughter.
- I wish I had a cousin.
Oh really?
- Yeah she was 18, I was 38.
- You're like the
Woody Allen of science.
- Well.